you're on the cover of
philadelphia-style and you look like a
sexy badass largest publications no it's
so funny because when you're a comic or
a comic actor and then they asked you to
make this face yeah I know you made a
lot of other faces but you make this
face yeah that's the one that they're
gonna you look like a gigolo they
surprised you while you were busy being
sexy yeah oh you made it when you're on
the cover of a magazine looking like an
absolute douchebag look you're like you
get a whole modeling shoot in here look
at this big car these are nice clones
Longshoremen's chic where's the shoot
Philadelphia no of course not yeah and
there's and you don't have any Cheez
Whiz on you so how is it Philadelphia
but no one says covered in Cheez Whiz in
Philadelphia whole city just cuz that's
all they do adelphia style is now are
you that's the thing is when you get in
this business and you get into it to be
funny and I've had this experience
sometimes where all I ever wanted to do
was was trying to be funny and then
someone wants to take your picture
and then they they take a bunch of
pictures of you and then they start
saying like look kind of soulful it's
like you're a man of mystery and I think
no I'm not a man of mystery I'm an idiot
I don't want to do that well I actually
got in the business to be extremely
handsome and people just know it's
really awkward they're like it's those
photo shoots are all about the clothing
so they like sir can you get out of the
way the jacket can you make your face
disappear can you no more caller hi
you're caller right so that's all that
Charlie day is wearing Sears and
roebucks you know yeah I suppose so
I know people in you know Philly like oh
this guy oh when I see him
you